[Music]
let's be done
right welcome everybody
and
first up i will call
recording in progress
call for uh apologies do you have any
apologies i'll just
try to work two screens here
no apologies
okay
conflicts of interest are any conflicts
of interest to be noted
appear to be done
um confirmation of minutes
so we hit seven minutes there pages five
to seven three point one it is uh can we
have a mover for those minutes
uh moved uh councillor redmond seconded
uh the mayor
i'll put that although are there any
corrections that anyone wishes to make
peter b nunn thank you um i'll put that
all those in favor
raise your hand raise your hand
against
carried thank you
all right
matters are rising no matter the rising
indicator
uh deputations there are nil so we'll
move straight to reports item 6.1
uh vanessa and shane is vanessa
and shane where are you
shane here
he was here he's gone
oh there it goes
right we will hand it over to you
welcome thank you so the purpose of this
report is really just to seek approval
to implement the six parking restriction
changes in the kai point town centre
listed in the report
we did enter a public consultation
period last year of three weeks just to
get community feedback and also some
feedback from the property owners and
directly affected businesses and you'll
see from those survey results in the
report most people were generally
supportive of the changes uh i'd also
like to note that the kaiapoi to ohio
community board have endorsed the
changes in a meeting on 21 fib um this
year so happy to take any questions
[Music]
any questions
council redmond
hello vanessa has there been any further
discussion with business owners since
the kaiapoi to ahiwee board meeting no
they no there hasn't
that's
uh
councilman
yes thank you mr chair um looks like
it's been
thoroughly canvassed and really good to
see the consultation i just wanted to
check about any residential properties i
know there's a rental property on raven
key um they're all happy with the fact
that they won't have parking outside
their property we didn't um canvass the
residential properties to be honest we
only went to the businesses and the um
the main sort of property owners in the
area so i i in terms of residential
feedback um i can't comment on that
why wouldn't you've notified the
residents with a letter that that there
was proposed changes outside their
houses um i think we were just focusing
mainly on the
it was on the park side so the actual
north side of the street
um there's a raven key you're talking
about um yes so so it's not going to the
south side that's right yeah um so in
terms of raven king i'm not too sure
where that residential property is so
you'll just have to enlighten me next to
the mandy tevin oh okay i'm not too sure
what that is so yeah i i'm just not
familiar with that property sorry in
this shane do you know it
no no i don't right
yeah sorry i can't i'm sorry i just
can't comment i don't know where that is
yeah
oh okay well hopefully it's been through
the board so they've they've they know
the resident's views in that area yeah
there was an actually a question um i
have a question just on that myself
is that i run a business from hilton
street never ever been approached and
neither is anyone in my staff i checked
um uh just last week no one has
approached them and then i
talked to the guys in the garage out the
back and according to them they had no
approach they didn't know what's
happening so
what's the
why is that
so when i did the flyer drop we i
basically primarily concentrated on
these these shops on william street
between hilton and raven key so i did a
fly drop into those shops because they
were the directly affected shops with
the parking immediately in front we've
always sort of said that we approached
directly affected shop owners and
property owners um the ones on the
periphery if they weren't if the parks
weren't immediately in front of their
their store or business we didn't tend
to do the fly drop on those areas and
and so that's the reason probably why if
you're talking about hilton street sort
of further away from those parks they
wouldn't have had received a flyer
we did actually have information on our
facebook page around about it as far as
put something up about it generally
but um the flyer drop was primarily
concentrated in those directly affected
properties and
tenants so
they are directly affected though
because around the corner if you move
them out of the main street around the
corner
into into those areas so why
i mean why would
a business owner on hilton street just
around the corner from the beginning
looks like it's probably why would they
look at the website if they know
nothing's going on there is no leaflet
drop there is no nothing
why would they look at the website for
what yeah i hear i hear comments
feedback around that i guess it was just
um
summer shops were when i actually did
the fly drop some shops weren't actually
open on the day so there will be some
that were missed um i yeah but
all i always basically have said i just
dropped flies onto those immediately
affected properties
i just uh
uh thanks for lisa uh and shane
just a question um
i was just looking for that in the
report and i may have missed it but it
was around that i get a lot of feedback
periodically around disabled parking can
you remind me
what's our process around that review in
the town please
i believe that's being looked at as part
of the accessibility strategy review
which is happening
at some point um this year is with the
policy team
members and my colleagues in my team
yeah
thanks
thank you
you're all mute
thank you mr chair i'm just following on
from your comment um vanessa were
leaflets delivered to businesses
upstairs yes yeah i know we had that
question about the um 137 william street
the law firm i did actually drop a flyer
and and
when i dropped these flies off i would
usually leave one or two and then ask
the reception staff to pass it on to
their staff or put it in the tea room so
beyond that i can't comment as to how
they were distributed internally once
they were actually dropped into the
businesses that were open so yeah
was there any thought given to posting a
leaflet to the right player
um i guess
i didn't consider that i'm ashamed i
don't know if that's something you guys
would normally do as part of your
transport
so i ask
why i guess yeah vanessa is the business
owners at 137
williams street upstairs we're una we're
unaware of the proposals right yeah i
know you mentioned that last time
council redmond so i did drop something
into them i just i guess it wasn't
passed on
i think i believe um let me just check
we had did work with communications on
this and there wasn't advice around um
doing a rate player right you know a
flyer drop out to rate pass so i guess
that's something at this level
um it was possibly felt it wasn't needed
um yeah that's
the only feedback i can provide
thank you vanessa just another question
so if this were to go through now and as
it is
what information will we be giving to to
um
business owners
the policies of those businesses and
your surrounding businesses before this
is enacted because i can see this and
just clarify i can see this as soon as
the signs change
exactly the same time
just like when you get your rates bill
the rate rate rise doesn't affect me
until such time as i have the bill in my
hand
and i just wonder
if there's another consultation to be
had that these are changing so that we
can if there are is it up or we'll say
or if there is a you know from people
surrounding whether that could be dealt
with before
the signs are changed is that a
possibility yeah absolutely i mean to be
honest this process is probably normally
the shame that might be one for you to
jump in on in terms of your process or
how transport normally manage these sort
of restriction changes to be honest this
is not something
my unit tends to deal with a lot of the
time so shane you might have comments
around that but certainly we can adopt
that in the process yeah yeah and we can
take that on going forward unfortunately
i i have not been through the
implementation process myself either so
we're a little bit limited in um how we
can speak of um previous uh exercises
although my understanding based on what
i have read i think as far as this
initial round of consultation i think
aligns with what we typically would be
doing again the frontage is initially
affected and of course i would speak to
the communications unit as we did when
we
undertook the initial process to get
their feedback as to the next steps
there will be some sort of internal
model that we follow when we do these
sort of changes or implement them
yes um just the statement at the top
that this has been endorsed already by
the kaiapoi tour herewith community
board in february 2022
um can you tell me
was it presented as a a consultation to
be done or was it endorsed as a an
actual recommendation by the community
board um i believe it was a
recommendation so we put these six
changes in front of them with the
community feedback that we had received
and they were happy for those to be
implemented
mr chair if i could just ask you were
you at that meeting and are you able to
um gauge your recollection were the
community to a community board happy
with
these recommendations
yeah look
i can't actually remember whether i was
here or not i knew you would come
outside question that's why and i'm
sitting in wrecking ball i think i was
and shane and vanessa probably um
remember better than me um and no they
weren't canvassed but i've had
personally i've had a couple approaches
since which has alerted me to my
questions that i'm
that i'm um um talking about so
um i'm pretty sure it wasn't but i
wasn't a witness to come to the
community board
well all these questions have been asked
i had to start a lot of reservations
about this um i'm just wondering whether
a way forward might be
to consider laying it on the table and
to go back out and talk to those
affected businesses that these changes
are coming and then come back after that
feedback's been received
missed
your 1 137 and williams street i just
don't want to but maybe i'm overreacting
here but i just think to myself that
this seems to me there's a lot of
a lot of confusion about what might or
might not be happening so whether it's
worth us laying this on the table and
procedurally if there's general support
for that or the staff might want to
respond i'd be happy to test the meeting
with them
i'll thicken that
all right
do you wish to comment shane or
[Music]
just one question mr chair sorry before
we go to the motion is it possible for
it to be
consulted with the club promotions
association too
thank you
thank you and we're sure and we should
as a part of that make sure we go back
to the board with that feedback before
it comes back here
okay
all right i'll put that all those in
favor
aye
against
carrick thank you very much
thank you thank you and shane
right now
all right
brennan's update we're in here
brendan isn't here
tracy do you wish to
i'm not restored anzac day
thank you mr chair um
brennan is due to be here i just wonder
would it be possible then we've got
shane here to go to
um
7.1 the referred report from rangiora
and then perhaps hopefully i'll just
quickly text brennan
if that was a possibility
sorry absolutely is
7.1 um
shine
and um i'll take it as red to just note
this originated from a request from the
bro school
to both
provide a bit of space for parents
dropping kids off and picking kids up
during those short hours and then at the
same time recognizing that the existing
24-hour bus parking was not used
for most that time for buses so trying
to do a little bit of a rationalization
for the reserve parking along the school
frontage
uh questions council today
yes
good um shane just a question please i
notice that quite a number of uh parents
actually park into the
the town hall um
car parking area so that's still
available for them to use that or are
you going to stop that parking there
we have no designs on changing anything
related to that being off the street
thank you that's good job
counselor
i think cancer ban that's moving i'm
moving
i finally breathed right okay
yes sorry happy to happy to move this
report um it was thoroughly it was
discussed at the rangarashi community
board it makes an awful lot of sense um
it's a short time where the the road
gets incredibly busy um and it
rationalizes some additional parking so
thank you very much to shane for your
work on this one it's a very common
sense solution to an appropriate
community request
endorse the comments entirely by
councillor barnett
i think it's a a very good report shane
common sense solution
it's an important area around there and
making sure that that flow works
for
the school is important in the safety of
of students which is an absolute um
paramount uh consideration for us i
think the point that counts the
dirty rays before is a valid one too
around the fact that there is the
ability to still use the town help cool
car park which i do see use that pick up
and drop off times quite a lot um is um
as we're out about so no i totally
support the recommendation a common
sense solution and thanks shane for your
work on
council meals
um yes look in addition to the
the comments about this being a common
sense move um i would also like to note
the fact that it
is quite a popular option for parents to
park in the council car park behind the
ranger a service center
at pick up and drop off times anyway and
that is still available to them so
um i don't see this as being um really
too much of a problem and it will
probably keep the traffic flowing a lot
better so i think it makes sense so
thanks for the report sheen and um yeah
happy to support this
okay any further speakers appear to be
none
uh i'll put that
recommendation all those in favor raise
your hand
against carrie thank you very much thank
you
right have we found the brenham and
brennan or is he out still swimming
somewhere
excuse me just i've just resent him the
link he was having trouble getting in so
he should be here with us momentarily
um
right okay we might take just five
minutes just while we're while we're
waiting
it shouldn't be too long at all thank
you
[Music]
are we all here who's missing no
warren's moved away we're all still here
aren't we yes we are all right
uh sorry bren brennan we'll uh we'll let
you take it away you are on mute
um
yeah so
what's been happening in our office
probably over the better part of the
last nearly 12 months actually is
routinely not an awful lot is happening
in terms of public engagement pretty
much nothing in terms of public
engagement actually
and our routine work has really been
around trying to get the training back
up and running particularly for the
volunteers and the cadets and a couple
of um very light skirmishes and
two
minor events
sorry am i coming across take a
a little muffled if you could speak a
little closer might
might help brenner but
we've got you but not probably not as
clear as it could be
okay i'll just uh
um
hopefully this is slightly better uh in
terms of emergency response events
what you see there in terms of saturn's
cause fire
and the nearness rainfall event are
probably um
well within everybody's memory at the
moment so we were lucky to dodge the
bullets there and got through with two
very um relatively low scale and almost
insignificant scale
emergency responses there and nothing
else including on the covert front has
emerged in this reporting period
in terms of the volunteers and the
cadets it's kind of where
in terms of what we're allowed to do
under the current code restrictions it's
kind of where most of our energy is
being spent at the moment other than
routine
collaborations with mainly the regional
soil defense office and the other
territorial authorities and our
emergency services partner agencies
around the volunteers and the cadets
we're quite pleased actually to see that
we haven't lost uh many at all
um we haven't lost any volunteers so our
numbers remain reasonably stagnant but
to me that's quite an impressive outcome
i did expect
that with the
covert restrictions we might lose some
volunteers and that has not been the
case
in terms of the cadets we've lost two
cadets who've moved on uh one of whom um
uh reached that age point
where she can no longer be part of the
cadets anyway and the other one has
moved on to do something else in life
there is a third one that i'm waiting
for confirmation from and i'll just have
to let the school holidays expire before
um i could reasonably expect him to
respond to all of our communications so
far so that will drop us down to um 17
cadets
and
the of those 17 they've been quite
actively participating in a number of
online sessions that paul has been
delivering
and the connection between paul and the
program and paul and the cadets has been
a really fantastic actually so he's
brought in some ideas of his own from
his experiences overseas and his work in
wellington and they've been well
received by both the volunteers and
cadets i think things are looking quite
promising on that front
and under the current covert
restrictions paul and i can't be in the
same in each other's presence physically
so we're still having to work um
virtually ourselves but despite that i'm
really wrapped with how he's joined the
team and fitting into the council
what's on the radar for us in the future
um as we're getting closer to the end of
a financial year there's a lot of
preparation as much as we possibly can
do to gear ourselves up to start
community engagement public engagement
um
whilst we've got tsunami and alpine
fault magnitude eight
uh themes in our on the back of our
heads
our approach actually is going to be
around trying the base
outcome that we want with communities is
more people being prepared to do things
to ready themselves for disaster and
being prepared to be part of
a small group residents neighbours
own response to an emergency
so we're doing a bit of brainstorming
background work to prepare ourselves for
that
and we're going to introduce
some of the ideas that paul has brought
from wellington and the wellington sword
defense office has done an awful lot of
work in the public engagement space
around setting up community emergency
hubs so that's kind of where we're
looking to in
the not too distant future is planning
for that
i think the rest of the items in the
report speak for themselves they're
relatively routine so i'll probably just
stop there and be happy to take any
questions
thank you brandon any questions brendan
ah thanks brennan um
when the tsunami presentations were
carried out in the coastal areas
um i think there was an offer to assist
some residents with their evacuation
plans has there been any progress with
those
uh yeah
so no there hasn't been one because we
wouldn't be able to actually make money
the pines beach residents association
who were at that particular meeting that
raised that interest
but when i say that we're preparing
ourselves to go out as soon as covered
restrictions allow us to start this
public engagement uh they're one of the
first target groups that we're we're
looking at because they've expressed
that interest and i'm guessing because
we haven't heard from them that we're
going to have to drive out there and
initiate the next contact with them but
they're definitely amongst some of the
very first uh community groups that we
intend to target
and um and i can see uh councillor
barnett in the background there so the
cast residents association likewise
signal uh interest in us talking to
their community and their group so
that's another targeted audience that
we're looking to go to straight away
and almost a year ago now
i'm seeing councillor meetings and
[Music]
we had a couple of lifestyle block
groups who were very interested in
developing uh similar plans that were
related to bushfires what they might do
to their livestock so those are four
instant
community target audiences that we're
looking to go to as soon as uh that
allows us
thank you
did everyone get that answered at the
start it was a little uh i thought
everybody's happy with the answers there
um brennan just a query please
with us when you're looking at this
community emergency hub and and moving
on
contacting people will you be doing the
neighborhood support group take will you
be taking them with you
yes do intend um
maybe if i just try turning that off
i'll just try another device that might
work better
can you hear me now yeah
yes
great
yes so um definitely intend to make
contact with sarah saunders um we did
talk with sarah before we went back into
this lockdown situation about our
intentions around this public engagement
and trying as much as possible
to align
uh what we do with the interested
community groups
with neighborhood support and get ready
if at all possible get ready to be in
the web based product that she uses
whether that's possible or not really
will depend on the people that uh that
have already joined up with um
neighborhood support and the gets
reading platform
um gets really itself as a technology
uh we're still being challenged in terms
of what sierra is able to do with that
and whether or not we can capitalize on
its functionality and then there's still
the question of whether or not her
residents are prepared to do anything
beyond
dealing with petty crime in their
backyards which has always been a
historical point of difference between
us and neighborhood support but it is
definitely our intention to try and
align
our work with her work and we do see
that um
the model that we're going to unleash
starting in july which we've taken from
wellington region
we believe that it's going to sell like
hot dogs to our residents who are
remotely interested in either
neighborhood support or having their own
community response plans
um and maybe uh closer to the time uh
this forum might like to see a
presentation around what the idea is
i think it's going to get some interest
from our residents
thank you my other question is you
mentioned about a community
emergency hub
uh i'm i'm sorry i'm not sure if
anyone's talking to me i can't hear
anyone has that answered the question
though
community emergency hub
no
i'm sorry i'm not hearing any voices
that's fun
take this off and just rely on the
speaker of the laptop
right um
he's got a question but i'm not sure you
can hear us can you bring it
no oh wait wait for a minute for him
can you hear us now
can you hear us
brenna no
don't worry i'll just pull out
wendy i'll i'll get um brennan to come
back to you i know
i think the questions if everyone's
comfortable with brennan's report i
think what we'll do is if we can nikki
um if the questions could be just
written maybe in the chat even that um
they might be able to be answered by
chat but um certainly tracy brennan
could get back to you um and the
committee with the with the answers to
your questions if that's satisfactory
um yeah your voice is booming in nice
and clearly for me at the moment okay
okay
quickly have a stab here um brandon just
two questions are you planning on um
doing any more af 8
work or will we have will we have that
presentation come back to us
thank you
just one other question please um
if he can hear me is that um i never
heard much back i set up for maria heppy
the collective action model um through
fenz that that um research that
you asked me to coordinate with some um
lifestyle block residents
probably about 18 months ago now and i
never really knew the outcome of that
and if that's going to be plugged into
anything we're doing here
so um yeah if you've if you've heard
anything and you can get back to me and
let me know um what came out of that um
i would be appreciative
but yeah always happy to work with you
on any of those kind of product projects
so
thank you for your work
all right thank you um
so as i say any of those any further
questions of brennan if you'd write
those and we can get them circulated to
the whole committee would be great
right i've had an indication from uh
councillor redmond that he wishes to
prove
uh brennan's report do i have a second
second council of millings
uh councillor redmond
right thanks very much brennan hopefully
you can hear
um
a good report i think it highlighted two
things for me one the difficulty of
inducting a new staff member during
covert times when you and paul are
unable to actually meet
i understand the reason for that if you
both fell out with covert we may have a
slight difficulty in the civil defence
area
and secondly it's pleasing to see that
you've still got 17 of the 20 cadets in
the program
given the hiatus we've had for the last
few months
so i look forward to that program
resuming in person
as soon as that's possible
so um thanks very much and um
obviously
internet connections than mandeville is
not that great
councilor williams
yes just just further to that
bran thank you very much for for your
usual awesome work um in this area in
some trying circumstances and yes
crap internet included
hopefully we'll get that fixed one of
these centuries hopefully soon um and
yeah keep up the good work and always
happy to work with you on anything that
i can help with um happy to support your
report thanks thank you
just to join in those comments but um
brennan excellent work as always but i'd
just like to endorse your remarks about
paul
paul kell i'm receiving really good
feedback about
what paul's doing with our groups
uh nz12 in particular seemed very
positive and their feedback which is
really excellent
and i was delighted yesterday to have a
member of the youth council um lady
wreath with me at um
rangyura but she was also dressed in her
cadet uniform um which was really
um which was
really great so two really good programs
that obviously we have a lot to do with
but we're gonna keep up the great work i
know it's trying in the current
circumstances but you're doing an
awesome job you and paul and i'm really
delighted with that feedback about paul
from people that are interacting with
them so you certainly settled in really
well so thank you
right
right of reply
uh councillor redmond writing for
employer all right then i shall put that
all those in favor raise your hand
against
carrie
thank you brendan
right
two computers
right i don't mind i have no
correspondence um portfolio updates so
accounts of anna
not much to say in the district plan
space apart from um
obviously our staff are very very busy
with all the new regulations that's
coming out of council that we're having
to do variations on the district plan so
it's very it's quite disappointing that
um after all the work that's been done
we're having to now make very sudden
changes with little consultation from
government
thank you any questions of councilman
thank you mr chair um it's about a month
since i caught up with tracy with
holidays and covert and things um but
there had been interviews underway for
the new esu manager
and i think that appointment's now been
made
and uh the person seemed to be very well
qualified for the position
um covered has been impacting on levels
of service
animal control and compliance have had a
reduced capacity
due to staff needing to isolate during
the last month or so
the unit is triaging
triaging customer service requests
so lower risk issues such as barking
complaints may have to wait until staff
are able to respond
um
a dog owner has lodged an appeal in the
district court in relation to an
infringement for not registering their
dog on time
i'm not sure if that's progressed in the
last month but normally the court
process is fairly slow
and we've had a report from brennan uh
today in the civil defence area
i understand that staff are under work
pressure in all areas due to the general
workload staff illness isolation leave
vacancies
uh covered
so um
they've they've
got it all so there has been some impact
on levels of service
and that's all from me thank you
thank you council redmond any questions
of council written
appear to be no well thank you for that
all right i have no questions
understanding orders no urgent general
business next meeting will be uh
the 21st of june on tuesday
and i declare the meeting closed
[Music]
you